actually coming from a caregiver line of
work and I'm now going to start coaching
you're talking about the VA where to get
the help or a VA so two options one
would be any personal connections that
you have a lot of the Home Care people
at least here in Canada are from the
Philippines so if you already have
connections in there there's a lot of
people in the Philippines also who are
doing VA work so it could be personal
connections and saying let everybody
know in your caregiver community that
you're looking to hire somebody in the
Philippines to help with your VA work
and you might you know land on somebody
great the good thing about that is
they're connected to the caregiver
Community already because their friend
their family of somebody who is a
caregiver here in Toronto right or
Canada those are some recommendations
letting your friends know hey I'm
looking to hire somebody who can do this
for me the second is we use upwork so up
like up and then work is where you can
hire people
around the world for different projects
um if anybody is hiring like you can
just go a lot faster
when you have people helping you and it
doesn't have to cost a lot of money like
when I was given the advice to Maria
I could have said hey Maria you go out
and make this list and you go out and
and she's already rolling her eyes she
could do it but for the amount that it's
going to cost her it's it's just not
worth it right it's just not worth it
for her to put the list together and
email people but for her to be on the
first call absolutely like we don't want
Dylan on is anybody here named Dylan I
don't think so we're using Dylan as an
example okay
um we don't want Dylan to be making the
first call because he probably won't
know what to say we need that to go to
Maria so like where is the highest
leverage for her
part-time worker overseas
um just makes a lot of sense and for a
lot of people like that's a great job
you know a lot of people who work for me
um
did not did not like their job prior
might have been traveling two or three
hours out of town like each way to get
to their job and come back to do some
call service you know call call center
service work
um you're gonna treat them like a human
being like they their boss I mean most
bosses suck so here you are like
actually caring about them
um so it's a great it's a great life for
them as well not just you know you get
work off your off your plate
um so yeah upwork is great what I'd
recommend for anybody who's looking to
hire an upwork is
even for even just hiring period work on
something small together first
work on something small together first
make sure you like them make sure
there's a good vibe there make sure
they're
um they're skilled they're doing the
work well
um they're not you know taking longer
than they should
um they're not
asking dumb questions or asking no
questions right like it's a good vibe
and so when we hire
we might we might end up hiring 10 or 20
people for a position where we have one
opening
and
we it's paid so like it's not just
volunteer for us but we'll pay them to
do a trial job and whoever really Nina's
the Nina's the asset test now you know
like if you're going to work at our
company you have to get along with Nina
well there's problems so so hey if you
if you like work Nina likes working with
you boom you're hired let's go and you
have the skill set obviously but it's in
that you know we'll give we'll hire
people for up to five hours on a job we
think should take two hours
wow amazing and then if the person who
we like working with the most who also
brings you know does the job obviously
but it was a pleasure working with then
um then we'll go deeper with them
um and that's what I love doing like
it's for me it's still Vibe first and
then this is like for submit here and
we're still around but
um
when you're hiring it's it's Vibe first
too like heart first he's there he's on
his phone like heart first on the hiring
and then still ahead you're not just
hiring somebody because you love them
when you think it's everything's gonna
work out and be amazing they still have
to be able to do the job but but heart
first like if you went to work and you
love the people you're working with
then um a lot more great things can
happen you know I mean like I see Zane
here when Zane Dan and I were talking
about
um him and Movie Makers and being
involved helping in the early you know
the intros for it and in the bill to
serve coach
I was looking for a built to serve coach
you know like I didn't I didn't I didn't
I didn't want one it wasn't it was not
on my roadmap or idealist but Zane was
one just so amazing as a human pouring
so much love into other people
and how much love he had for Bill to
serve was amazing like he knows the book
better than I do
uh He's like Paige 85. here's what it
says he's got copies that are falling
apart because he's read it so much like
the pages are falling out and all over
the place uh it's just like I love this
human
we should I need to do something with
him
like I need to find a way to do
something more with him and so that it
led to this right so I think you should
yeah Vibe first and so you won't know
that just by um
by a cover letter
it's also like the recommendation to
Chris to actually fly out or drive out
eight hours ago see the guy because he
can feel like the heart
you'll get a you'll get a better
structure and a better deal likely than
even definitely over an email but then
doing it over a zoom
yeah
thank you so much
I have a technical question though if I
if I want to search for people on
Instagram in my Niche because I also
work with women that are me wanting to
release weight and more emotional eating
and it's a sensitive issue
um
do I just in the search put hashtag what
I'm looking for and then what happens or
tell me what to do like the technical
piece yeah so in the search bar at the
top it depends if you're using desktop
or mobile but still this you can search
you put in hashtag emotional eating
but then it brings it'll often bring me
to like somebody who's well like I just
put in women weight loss and then it
comes to some like a coach that's like
that's her page
so it'll give you options you can do
people and also say hashtags you can
click on the hashtags and then see okay
another way around it is you when you're
searching like women weight loss don't
put a space in there
because hashtags can't have spaces right
I mean sometimes underscores whatever
but but you will get a mix of people who
are also doing what you're doing those
are the people that we want to skip
okay right like more than one comes up
like you go to different hashtags so
when you go to that hashtag does it open
up all I'm sorry I'm like really
learning how to do Instagram yeah yeah
yeah no that's good when you click on a
hashtag it'll show you what
the top posts are for that thing and
then the most recent posts as well I
would have showed me the posts okay and
then and then you can click on them and
see so you're you're going after the
people who are not like you unless you
have a model right like maybe part of
Chris's new business could also be
also helping other people who are
trainers train better
you know like if he's searching up Dad
bod he'll get some people who are also
trying to promote their personal
training business yeah and he could
reach out to them and say hey I've been
doing this for X number of years if you
need help growing your business
I I'm happy to hop on a call and help
you
right so that's a different model I
don't know if Chris wants to go after
that audience or not other other
trainers he's like maybe like cool you
know like ditch it I don't care
options right so they're your
competition and you don't you don't have
anything to help them with then you skip
them and move to the people same thing
for you like you'll have you'll have
emotional eating as a hashtag and you
get some people who are deeply in it and
are frustrated with it and are just
seeking some kind of validation or
emotional support by posting on
Instagram
and that's a very empathetic
Outreach you'll have other people though
who are making fun of it who are posting
like a cartoon or a funny meme or and so
then you lean in on the humor and you
can say hey but if you actually sung
with us I could help you and your and
the goal is to flip them and so just
play with both and then see which one
one feels more natural and heartfelt for
you and two where you're getting results
from people yeah
I have one more question if that's okay
yep so my word really lends itself to
working in collaboration with
nutritionists with um you know I'm a
food psychology coach but I I work
really with addictive you know the
addictive piece of doctors people that
have clients that are struggling and
they know what to do but they just can't
do it
so is that something on Instagram that I
would do like maybe reach out to people
with those niches also and and see about
some form of collaboration yep Instagram
and maybe LinkedIn
this is where I would see like the
challenges that the people who are at
the top
probably aren't making a lot of content
like the top Professionals in almost any
field are not making a ton of content
most of them
so are the top doctors making a ton of
Instagram content probably not maybe but
in professional Fields doctors lawyers
accountants generally really suck at
making content that just all referral
based business and they're not you know
some are but for the most part they're
not
um but you could like if you put
nutrition tips
or nutritionist you know as as a search
in Instagram you'll see who's posting
all of those people are they're giving
their nutrition tips or their
nutritionist uh you have to do a little
bit of work to see how you know is this
person of a certain level I don't know
how you know they're just getting
started maybe it's not worth the time
um but it's a great way to find partners
for your business especially if it's
anywhere in the US like if you can
partner with somebody in LA or in
balmy Cleveland
yes you know
um yeah it's a great way to be able to
find people and set up some partnership
Arrangements you'll just get a bunch of
people who also are the early stage of
their company and may not be able to
give you a lot of referrals so it might
be it might be some Tire kicking there
um until you find the ones you can you
can gain a sense like do they have their
own location you know do they have a
retail Center do they have a place you
can actually go visit them or is it just
a home office or all online you know
just to have some criteria for who you
work with but um I love Partnerships
because
they can instead of going one to one to
one to one now you're targeting one
person they can introduce you to ten 100
000 people yeah yeah well my had my
brick and mortar business my best
referral was through a naturopath Clinic
because they had me go there regularly
meet the clients and and they you know
they weren't able to do with the
naturopath was asking them to do and I
was helpful in helping them do that
could you do that anywhere in North
America
yeah if I mean virtually yeah I mean
honestly it might even be better since
you've already done that with naturopath
clinics
um I would look at hiring a VA
to make a list of every naturopath
clinic in North America
and then give them a give them a Maria
lipuma email address
you know Dylan at Maria lipuma
and now Dylan is emailing everybody to
say
hey would you like to talk to Maria
about this
right that's great and you create a
little script for them to send off like
Dylan is not a full-time person at your
company Dylan's just researching and
sending out emails from your company
and then when they say yes most people
will ignore it or goes to spam or
whatever great
and then some people will say okay yeah
let's hop on a call
and then Dylan gives it to you and Maria
takes over honestly like that's if you
have that model already worked out it's
already happened for you that'll be
faster for you to grow your business and
I can use testimonials and all that in
the yeah all you need to do is get
somebody on a call
because you've already done it before
that'll be much faster than doing it
through social media
okay so so hiring a VA to get me a list
of the naturopaths in North America and
sort of create an email that they can
just send out inviting them to have a
chat with me
okay great great idea thank you Evan oh
thank you so much for what you bring I'm
just amazed by you you're an amazing
powerful power of example I know I'm
embarrassing you but really
I'm gonna turn I'm going to turn this
red now I'm going to turn that color on
my face now because of you Maria
um but listen as much as I love content
and YouTube it it's not always the best
Next Step right like honestly for you
you just need to have enough of a
profile that if they look you up on
Instagram there's something there or
YouTube like there's something there for
putting your name like who is this Maria
person is she legit there's something
there that shows enough of what you do
um yeah and then the VA is making the
email list
you have to make the email don't expect
them to like write the email right you
make the email and then the VA is
sending out the email
how many how many natural path clinics
are there in North America
I mean
crazy a lot yeah I mean in my town in
the next two towns around here there's a
lot yeah so if you have like if you get
one percent of one percent of one
percent you already have more business
than you know what to do with that's
great
smart asked uh why mindset matters and
so just you know quick riff I guess on
mindset I think lack of belief is the
world's biggest problem right like
whether you believe you can or you can't
you're right and most people are just
stuck most people feel trapped most
people are around other negative people
who also feel trapped and so you might
occasionally have this idea that great
things are possible but then you fall
back to the negative mindset and
everybody else around you and you stay
stuck
um I just came back from a
from speaking at two events in in
Phoenix a genius Network and the first
one people paid 25 000 a year to be in
the second one and you pay a hundred
thousand dollars to be in and my uh my
last day I had a morning coffee with a
guy who had sold his business for over
200 million dollars
and now it's helping other entrepreneurs
be more efficient and productive in
their businesses and
you know he picked me up from my hotel
and we drove this house and then he
eventually drove me to the airport and
his house is more like a compound it's
just not it's not just a house it's like
a house and then an entire house just
for his recording studio for he plays
guitar in another house just for his
Taekwondo studio for him to practice and
like four houses in one house and
more than any bit of advice that he gave
me and similar to just being in those
groups it's the the mindset difference
it's like trying to do
life at a bigger level trying to have an
impact at a bigger level and for most of
us we are that source of positivity for
other people we are the ones believing
in other people and pouring into other
people and telling them that they can do
it and giving them love and
encouragement and support but who's
telling us that we can do better and in
a loving way not like you should be
doing this this we got lots of those
people but who's pushing your loving way
forward and for the most part we don't
have those people so that's why I love a
group like this that's why I love groups
like movement makers
um and just in general trying to be
around more optimistic positive people
because sometimes it's hard for Carrie
for us to carry the whole burden of
positivity and optimism for ourselves
and so if you are the most optimistic
person you know that's in your immediate
circle
um that's a problem you know like it's
great that you can don't stop pointing
other people but if you don't have
anybody who's pointing into you then
that keeps us stuck and it keeps us
small and so the mindset shift a few
you're like hey I can do more I can be
more I can serve more I can have a
bigger impact I think becomes really
important so the the whole idea of you
are the five people you surround
yourself with really matters and if you
don't know anybody then get in a group
or come back to you know a group like
this
um or even just through content
right that I haven't met Elon Musk yet
but I I get inspired by his videos and
his content and his moves like Elon Musk
is buying Twitter what doesn't he
already have four of the companies that
he's running or something it's like it
just makes me question what I'm doing
not in a negative way like I think
comparison actually can be really
beneficial a lot of people say don't
compare yourself to others and I think
people just compare themselves
incorrectly they look at somebody else
and then they kick themselves down say I
can't do it where I like it as a kick
forward say wow look what Elon Musk is
doing I can I should be thinking bigger
and it's an inspiration to go off and do
more otherwise we stay stuck and stay
small
um so anyway that's my little quick Riff
on why mindset matters thank you Samar
for the topic and uh let's let's open it
up Tony's got his hand up what do we got
Tony
I have a personal training and nursing
coaching business for 35 years now and
for 33 years I was doing everything in
person until covet hit switched
everything virtual and online
but for probably the past eight years
since I was about 45-ish years of age
I've been posting non-stop Monday
through Friday on Facebook I've been
emailing Monday
through Friday to meals I started doing
Instagram maybe a couple years ago as
well I feel lost in that kind of virtual
world so
we went through a great exercise this
morning Movie Makers where I'm I'm
basically I told them that my number two
platform is now Tick Tock we decided
last week that YouTube is number one and
it still is number one by far but I've
switched in the past week from Instagram
to tick tock as number two and so part
of it is being smart with where you're
at because you could you could be
producing the best content ever but if
you're on Facebook like Facebook has
been dead for a long time right there's
no zero organic reach on Facebook it's a
fantastic ad platform but it it sucks
for Content
um Instagram
is
slowly not dying but becoming less and
less and less and less and less relevant
it's harder to rank it's harder to win
um we covered a little bit today but the
reels is still going to be your best bet
now like no more pictures it's reels so
I need to see reels I need to see short
form video content
um and then Tick Tock is definitely
picking up steam like we're over half a
million followers on Tick Tock and a
quarter million on on Instagram and
it's taken me like six years to do that
on Instagram in a year and a half or
whatever on Tick Tock and we're barely
taking Tick Tock seriously right like
Instagram's been number one and we just
kind of post whatever to tick tock and
the thing is blowing up
um and it's becoming an education place
as well for people so it's not just
somebody commented like 16 year old
teenagers dancing or whatever they're
still that and there's fun but it's also
becoming an education platform and these
the easiest thing to do is go search for
what you're doing
what you teach and and see what's on
there and you'll see that hey there's
actually education content on there so I
love that you're making content and I
love that you're an expert you've been
doing this for so long and you want to
serve
um I would look at
if I was getting started now and I
didn't have traction I would do YouTube
long form
and Tick Tock short form but then I
bring to the other platforms
um I would probably completely abandon
Facebook unless it was just easy to post
or you had some kind of community there
already
um and the long-form YouTube videos
would be
not hugely impactful in the short term
but you've been doing this for a while
and you want to keep doing this and so
um
getting whether their actual workout
videos that you're going to do whether
they're coaching sessions that you have
with clients uh you're imagining
someone's going to see this in a year
and two years and three years and love
what you're doing and sign up YouTube is
the if you want to get off the kind of
rat race you know the hamster wheel
whatever YouTube is it because when you
make content in a year it's still
relevant and valuable and can drive
traffic every other platform is it's
insta like Instagram it's instant it's
only what's happening right right right
right right now it doesn't mean that I
can't help or can't convert but Choice a
platform in in choice of content like if
you're doing pictures on Instagram it's
just gone off a cliff
so it's short form video Everybody Wants
short form video now plus long form on
YouTube so I'd look at a if you're not
consistent on YouTube yet I'd look at
once a week making content 10 minutes
plus no upper limit on how long you can
go
and then a daily short form for tick
tock that then you take to the other
platforms
great thank you okay let's move on lady
Lexi what do we got hi there okay
um
today is the Dutch Liberation day 77
years ago there are a number of
festivals they are still going you see
Liberation day yeah Dutch Liberation day
okay great well happy happy Liberation
day yeah so that's my fifth and um was
that thing going on I'm like I need to
go to Rotterdam go to one of those
festivals and make a recording but I'm
like okay what exactly am I going to
talk about I cannot just address all the
people there because I don't have a
fresh batch or anything so how do I make
that work because I feel like it's so
important that we get to speak out and
and so I can either go there or I can do
it from here what what would you suggest
what hold on what are you speaking out
again so it's okay Dutch Independence
Day cool today is 77th anniversary oh
that we got liberated by the English and
by the American and there might even be
some Canadian
okay so the idea is hey you need to like
you want to recognize them
haven't I don't know was a revolution or
was it a you know like how like they're
speaking up for themselves it's so
important
and I mean especially when with what's
going on in the Ukraine it makes my
heart cry since my my mother is about
speaking up and speaking out this is
about people back then were of course
being uh uh delegated basically to to do
the to the camps and put work there and
they were not recognized as people
so it's not necessarily that I want to
speak out for what happened there I just
want to you know say like okay let's
celebrate freedom let's remember that
it's important that we do speak up and
speak out
what we what we see and what we find
should change and also on a personal
level
so I mean that could be a great so if
the message is speaking out for Freedom
then that's something that people can
connect with because we want to Target
ideally the world not just
Holland right so most people wouldn't
know
that it's dutch Independence Day or how
many however many years it's been or how
Holland even came out of you know like
most people know the story and the story
Almost Doesn't Matter unless it really
means something to you but if you were
gonna go and make it not just what
happened 77 years ago but where do
people need more freedom right now like
it's a good trigger as a reminder so I'm
Canadian and but like we don't uh we
don't we have we have Canada today but
it's not really that big a deal in
Canada
um but Americans take their independence
day pretty seriously right and so on
July 4th in America if you were to go
off and talk to people about about
freedom
but then make it reflective as to where
do you not have enough freedom in your
life right now
and not just from like the government
imposing something on you but your own
situation like where are you stuck in a
relationship are you stuck in a bad
career are you stuck in bad habits are
you stuck with an addiction like if you
can tie the need for freedom to
something they're facing right now in
their life then it can lead to speaking
up like for yourself if you're in a bad
relationship hey maybe you need to get
out if you're in a bad career maybe now
is the time so you can use this event as
a spark plug to create some change so
you could go if you want to go to the
event you don't need a you don't need a
press badge to talk to people
you just go on the street and you ask
people about what Freedom means to them
but then make it relevant to today like
well where do you not have enough
Freedom right now do you think in your
life
and then guiding them to a path of
speaking up
okay uh okay yeah it's going to be a
mixed up for me you know addressing
people randomly at a festival
um but yeah listen lean in on that
because this is now you speaking up
yeah that's good yeah it's a good
challenge absolutely this is I've never
done it before and this is now you
going after your freedom because you
don't want to be you don't want to have
that blocking mindset anymore
yeah and you may have people who say no
and I want to talk to you no I hate you
I mean whatever you're like speaking
like worst case scenario
um but you'll have some people who will
talk to you
yeah yeah that's nice and then maybe I
can do some shorts some short lives and
then later on make it into a big one and
post it on YouTube honestly the biggest
thing the biggest win out of all of this
isn't the content you're going to get
from them it's from you pushing yourself
outside the comfort zone
okay that makes sense the fact that like
one person might say yes to you and
you're so scared to ask people to come
on and then you get one person to do it
even if it's not the greatest
conversation of all time like that
forward momentum and you breaking
through like that should be a video you
should film yourself going
and how scared you are and what whatever
thoughts are in your head
and you're basically speaking up to your
own thoughts to say you know what no I'm
gonna I'm gonna go do this and even if I
if I embarrass myself if nobody talks to
me
I'm still gonna go off and do it I saw a
great clip yesterday on Instagram where
um these these um this guy was a
stutterer
so like he gets nervous and then he
can't talk and and his coach I know you
guys have seen this his coach had him go
out in a busy area and go up to people
and ask them to like hey can you help me
for a second and all he then would ask
him is what time is it but it took him
forever to get it out because he was so
nervous and when he gets nervous he
starts to stutter and so he's like
excuse me
like they're sitting there waiting for
him to like what's going on right now
and eventually he says you know what
time is it and
um he also just shared the story with
them like I must I'm a stutterer and I'm
trying to
be less scared and stutter less as this
is part of my my homework so even you
sharing your story like that's like the
biggest win of all that you share in
your story that where you're afraid and
the mental block
um so that you get your own freedom from
those limiting thoughts too
yeah that's a good one so I can just
take my phone I don't need any
microphones or anything right yeah
especially if you're doing two people
because if the microphone's just here
then it's harder to share
and don't worry about the gear just go
do it
okay yeah I'll do thank you I love it
cool good luck that's super exciting
so I've actually
um been following you for a couple of
years now
and I finally had the courage to begin
to do my YouTube work right
so I live in Nigeria and I kind of like
what you do you know showcasing
entrepreneurs and thought leaders
so most of the time when I come to your
channel I don't see
a lot of Nigerians a lot of Africans and
you know there are people on the
continent doing great things
you know and for me your book one word
has helped me to clarify my one word you
or or phrase as you recall it to be big
performance you know and you have also
helped me with a lot of your work to
understand my why my who my words and
all of that you know so
I'm having all of this Clarity you know
my platform my go-to platform is YouTube
so I started to work on my YouTube
channel early this year now
great I'm growing it organically you
know today I celebrated 700 the last
time I checked it's on 700.
oh man that's great
thank you many thanks to you though wait
when how long ago did you start
I started working early this year
so look if you go to my website actually
I can even share it
you have 704
yes that's Peak Performance Academy
that's the name of the website okay but
look look this is my and for anybody who
wants to check like you can see I put
this on my homepage
yeah it took me one two three four years
to get the 775
you're you're
25 subscribers you're one so you're at
704. you're you're ahead of me by by
three years so I I'm I love it dude
congrats so so it's because you know I'm
modeling you as a master so it's a kind
of half my journey because success
leaves clue Tony Robbins has taught us
that over and over again now what I just
want you know you to help me do is take
a look at my channel what am I doing
right so that I could double double down
on because for me it's about thought
leadership is about getting monetized
you know it's about expanding you know
my reach and the value I can bring even
to my audience so I just want you to
tell me what I'm doing right and what
I'm doing wrong so that I can go back
and do the work and get monetized and
even give more value
uh sure so let me let me actually pull
up the channel and see
see what we can do to get some feedback
I love we've done some African
entrepreneurs
um we've done aliko dangote we've done
strive Massey Ewa we've done a whole
bunch of people
um yeah I I just I just describe my CUA
and I also did um
700 plus views in fact the last time I
checked 800 plus views is on fire
but he's not is he Nigerian no he's a
South African yeah busy is amazing Bruce
is one of the guys like most people in
North America don't know who aliko
dangote is
but like he is like the man in Africa
like insane one of the richest people in
the entire world
um and he doesn't do a ton of interviews
same with like strive master yiwa and a
bunch of the guys who don't do a lot of
content but but vusi is if you guys
don't know vusi tembeque I forget how to
put
pronouncing his last name took me
forever I hate getting people's last
names wrong it took me so long to get
tembaqueo down because it's not a normal
like in Canada you know we don't so it
took me but now that it's one of those
names that once you get it you don't
forget it it's like absolutely it just
rolls off the tongue now anyway okay so
let's look at the uh let's look at the
channel here so Peak Performance Academy
cool I put your face up here so people
can know who you are I zoom in on this
as well so it's you can see the face
more uh I would not do a welcome to my
YouTube channel don't put an intro put
your best video so if the vusi videos
question for you make that your channel
trailer
Nigerian
no stride must UI is a Zimbabwean boy
lives in UK now right but you put how a
Nigerian oh Governor requested per Vibe
okay okay
yeah it does did some shots you know you
also got me to Big doing shots so I did
a shot for busy and he got a good you
know response
yeah I mean you might also if you're
going to lean heavily into the African
Community I would put that up here
because who else is targeting I mean
it's a giant giant I mean I don't have
to tell you how big Africa is it's just
it's insane and nobody's nobody is
really that I know targeting it well so
you could be the guy but when you do
this Peak Performance Academy this looks
like a junior Brendan Bouchard you know
like because he's all about Peak
Performance Academy or pre-performance
coaching I forget what this program's
called but you look like a mini Brendan
burchard as opposed to like being you
could be the guy for Africa
okay
so face and just if if you want to go
all like oh there you got Ali gode this
guy's awesome
um
yeah so I would I would switch up The
Branding to be about Africa if that's
what you're going to be creating content
around
um the next thing is I would uh
the the titles are like the thumbnails
are okay it's a little too much text
too much effects
looking this on the phone
it's got to be smaller
uh and then never put text in the bottom
right because you see here wanted gets
covered up by the timestamp
and when it's on the phone it's even
bigger so people won't be able to read
they may not be able to read wealth and
they definitely won't read I wanted
so that's why if you look at ours and
and others that we've influenced the the
face is on the right side and the text
is on the left side
okay
you have good contrast uh with the
colors like the yellow the the blue and
the white I might pick I mean this your
branding I know this colors that like
are more
African like I don't know what the like
what are the Nigerian flag other other
colors like if I was doing a channel for
America I would go red white and blue
Captain America like those are the
colors other other
I don't know enough about Africa but I
wouldn't I wouldn't associate blue as
being like a primary color if I look at
African flags I don't see a ton of blue
in there I might just be a complete
idiot but that's where like you might
want to think about if we're if we're
going online on African entrepreneurs
like what's the Nigerian flag
it's green white green green and white
African flags
I guess it's a little blue on the what's
that Zimbabwe
um
but like
I mean yeah like this is you know
it's the red the yellow the green a
little black that's what I would play
more in then
blue
okay it just represents the culture of
the people that you're trying to Target
a lot more
[Music]
uh the text is a little this font this
is something that lady Lexi and I were
were
how many conversations are we having
about fonts font choices it was a lot uh
this is one of those where it's like you
don't want the font to be hard to read
so when you look at this one you see Dad
and dreams you're using like an army
style kind of font but it's it makes it
more difficult to read
like it says at least 10. it was a lot
and I feel so bad because she'd be like
how about this one's like no no how
about this one no I'm sorry no
so uh yeah so like the my the other the
words that are in white
are easy to read even though they're
smaller the words that are in the the
Army font it's just hard hard to read so
like if it's hard to read then guess
what people won't read it and they'll
skip it and go to the next thing so we
need it to be easier to read yeah and
then the words per Post Yeah so like my
dad said no to my dreams five lines of
text is too much
but then look at the aliko dangote one
it's like so many so many lines it's
like nobody's gonna be able to see that
there's just too too many too much text
okay
um so that's just from like a thumbnail
I hope this is helpful for everybody as
well I miss you on the gaming channel
right yeah yeah it's freezing it's
freezing
is it freezing for everybody or is it
just
I think it's my next question Terry's
saying no
okay so no well this part's being
recorded so you can you can watch back
and see but
um yeah the gaming channel was super fun
lady Lexi uh yeah I don't know we might
get back to it
all right so that's like thumbnail title
long form was great uh your most popular
video is you know Lucy so you're doing
27 20 30 34 10 these are great
um
I would never use black and white on the
thumbnail doesn't do as well
right
right like even even look at uh look at
busy
right and then look at you
now
and look at the skin tone right now I
don't know like how much
um I don't know if you have the exact
same like skin tone as Lucy but look at
the light on his face look how much
brighter he is than you are here
if it's brighter more people click on it
so even in looking at us now but you've
got some light on your face you're
brighter even though you're like you're
at home and whatever you get but is it
some kind of light on your face you're
brighter it's easier to click especially
when you have a dark background like
this blue is dark and your jacket like
Blends completely into the into the blue
and the because your your face is darker
uh it Blends in as well where you want
it to pop and stand out where vusi
stands out why because he has light on
his face
she stands out too because there's
lighter on her face this one I would
just never do black and white even here
if you look at this guy he's got light
on his face
versus yours where there's no light
this one will stand out more
right so I would just add more uh either
put a light on your face or use a
different picture
so that it will it'll stand out more for
you
um and then lastly we actually just like
click and Watch What Happens
okay so you're getting right into
content like that becomes the most
important thing if diving right into the
content
depending on the sources you might get
dinged for copyright uh or blocked or
strikes you got to watch out about that
um but the key is not having really long
boring intros
what happens here
this is an interesting experiment
like leaving with the music
yes you just pay attention to the
retention curves on the videos and how
it's working most people have like
really long boring intros
yeah this right like this sucks
right welcome to the whatever whatever
the place where you learn whatever no
like everybody's out forget I don't
watch this like you got to go right into
right into the content no intros
so endless everybody I did this too
this is why I sucked Michael yeah
at least part of why I suck right
um because people don't know who you are
yet
because we're attacking people we're
trying to Target people who don't know
who we are and they don't they don't
have time to sit like this very short
attention span now if Zan was doing this
and I know Zan and I love Zan I'll sit
through Zan talking for 20 seconds
before watching this content but Zayn
doesn't want to attract people who only
know him he wants to attract new people
right so if I didn't know you and I see
this like I'm not going to watch this
and you'll you'll see that in your
retention care people are just bouncing
right away so for everybody it's like
right to the content what are we talking
about get right to the content and if
you're going to say something about
yourself it's later in the video but not
at the beginning
so it looks like you're doing that a
little bit for some of the newer ones
wow look at this this is awesome
that's crazy
I love his outfit there
anyway uh but again like way too much uh
way too much text on this okay yes I'm
going to work on the text yeah and
listen that's an ongoing it's an ongoing
struggle and an ongoing opportunity to
learn how to again look at lady Lexi we
went through
so many variations of how many words
on a thumbnail
like hers were at the beginning ones
were rough you know because because like
you have so much you want to say right
it's like I got so much I want to say
and share uh but then like it becomes so
much and then there's nothing and then
and then we cut it down a little bit and
he's like okay that's progress but more
like more yeah more and then that we
made progress and then it got better
right uh so same thing some of these are
good
uh but never full sentences and just
think about how to get it as tight as
possible if you're also one last thing
if you're using uh faces and this works
if you're doing a profile or if you're
using
um like podcast you have any guest on
your podcast you look at this here right
so if we look at this one and we look at
uh aliko dangote aliko dangote this
could be doing much better but it's also
he's really dark like it's going to be
hard to see
you need a brighter picture
he kind of just Fades into the
background right or you need to do a
white background or a yellow background
or something that would make him stand
out more right
um but look at these two okay I know who
aliko dangote is
so I would recognize his face you don't
need to put the name in the I would I
would suggest never putting the name on
the thumbnail
okay because I know who he is
so putting aliko dangote in a name
doesn't add any value because I already
know who he is
we go to Mo abudu how about pronounce it
okay
um yes
she's big on the continent awesome and
look at how bright she is like look how
much this stands out
compared to the one next to it right so
okay moabudu I don't know who she is I
don't recognize her but then saying Mo
abudu on the thumbnail means nothing to
me too
so
if I know if I recognize the face the
name doesn't mean anything it's not
adding value and if I don't recognize
the face the name also doesn't mean
anything it doesn't bring any value
so there's no there's no case where the
the name adds value unless you're not
going to put the picture at all
right but the face will always do better
so instead of this like wisdom from
moabudu I don't okay I mean I don't know
who moabudu is so why do I care about
her wisdom tell me what I'm gonna learn
okay now again if people are if people
are they know her already like how do
you not know mo Voodoo every man she's
so big cool maybe I should profile her I
don't know I'm down I'm looking for more
awesome women to profile by the way so
that's great
um let me give you some ideas I have um
this woman in Nigerian she's currently
the director of World Bank
ngozi on kojo she's a former Minister in
Nigeria
she'll do great for more like
entrepreneurs as opposed to people in
like like director of the World Bank
um but I'm still I'm still I'm
definitely open like we struggle on on
on women content
um I'm always like it's probably one of
the biggest fights I have in my team
it's like so don't take a look at
following she's a woman bolognaire she's
from Nigeria her oh no
where's oh here
yes yeah so anyway so yeah I would just
take off the name tell me why I need to
click on this
okay this is how to make a great impact
doing what you love like you can make
that's impossible like it's too small
nobody's gonna read that too many words
tighten this down what's the biggest
lesson take away from watching this
video that I'm gonna get and use their
face but don't use their name
um
and that's an ongoing Challenge and a
good skill to learn of how to write
better short copy on your thumbnails on
your titles on your websites and your
headlines and your emails because we
have a lot to say
and that's great you have a 20 minute
video to say it but what's the most
important thing that's what needs to be
put on the thumbnail
the poll question was from Michael who
said owning your time in schedule so
my quick take on this and then we'll get
to you know questions from you guys
whatever I can help answer in this
little mini break for us today
um I love energy zones I think I think
staying in the same energy Zone really
really matters so today is Thursday uh
all of my public facing stuff is on a
Thursday I had I start with movement
makers which always gets me I'm an
introvert right so I don't wake up and
like hey Michael Jordan just in time
we're doing your question right now
Michael drive safe though drive safe
um we uh you know I get so much love
from Movie Makers that that that gets me
fired up for the rest of the day and so
all I have to do on a Thursday is do my
public facing stuff so all day long it's
just interviews and and sessions like
this and podcasts and better Movie
Makers and then three podcasts and then
this and then like four more podcasts
and then live streaming tonight but I'm
not worried about my YouTube channel I'm
not worried about my team I'm not
worried about anything else besides just
spreading the message today and I think
it's great to stay in that energy Zone
because the energy I got from Movie
Makers I'm still pouring into the next
group and the love I get from you guys
I'm pointing to my podcast right after
this and so I don't have to switch I
think switching between different tasks
ends up being really really it's
challenging for everybody maybe extra
challenging for me
um because I think to spend half an hour
on a podcast and then 20 minutes writing
the book and then 40 minutes doing
something else you end up just getting
nothing done you feel like if you ever
felt like I worked all day but I got
nothing done
it's probably because you're switching
between energy states too much and so
all I have to worry about today is this
one thing of spreading the message
um
yesterday was my project day
so this this is a change that I made in
the past year or year and a half that
really made a huge impact was adding
project day in the middle so Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Tuesday is my YouTube
day it's crazy it's crazy it's just I
gotta make videos for 12 different
channels plus two strategy plus it's
just all day long if you're on my team
don't try to reach me on a Tuesday it's
not going to happen I'm just making
videos
Thursdays today is crazy crazy just all
day long interviews and podcasts and
Skypes and just all day long so in the
middle Wednesday is open day Wednesday
is my project day Wednesday I wake up
I'm like what do I want to work on today
um it doesn't turn into like let's play
League of Legends all day like I like
working but I get to basically pick
whatever project I want to work on and I
like having the freedom
in the middle of the week between the
two crazy days it used to be like write
my book day right you know if I'm right
in the book I need a whole day it's hard
to write a book in 20 minutes a day
because it takes you 20 minutes just to
get back into what you were doing any
kind of creative work if you're doing
creative work you need like chunks of
time without the stress of I need to be
done by one o'clock so it can go off and
do this thing that kills your creativity
so Wednesday's creative work day
um and and I'm just trying to get way
way way way way way more stuff done
working the same number of hours but
just way more productive because I'm not
shifting my energy too much now you may
not be in complete control of your day
you might have a job you might have
customers you might have other
responsibilities family whatever so
whatever is inside your calendar that
you can control just being more
intentional with it
and making sure that what's in your
calendar is going to help you get your
goals right like if you want to have a
YouTube channel I was talking about just
before this was on a podcast with the
guys like help me build my YouTube
channel okay great well show me where in
your calendar have you dedicated time to
make YouTube videos
oh I haven't done that well that's why
you're not making YouTube videos dude
it doesn't ever happen it's like yeah
that's why I haven't made a video in the
past three months okay great so it's
it's we can change that we can add that
we can put it in
um but your actions have to be you know
map to your Ambitions what's in your
calendar has to be the thing that you're
working towards every day so I like
different days for different things I
have my morning routine which I do every
day and then I fall into whatever that
day is going to be so mentoring day
Monday YouTube day Tuesday uh
Wednesday's open project Day creative
day Thursdays public facing day
interviews Friday is CEO day grow the
business Saturday is fun day
and then Sunday's family at midday and
even that's an important distinction
Sunday is
go grocery shopping do the laundry
uh
uh whatever I mean whatever has to get
done clean up the condo
you know all the all the stuff that you
have to do to live life that is not fun
but that's kind of required be honest on
a Sunday but it's not on Saturday
I'm not folding laundry on a Saturday
is the only day where we don't even do I
don't even do the dishes you normally my
wife cooks and I do the dishes after not
Saturday Saturday
I'll leave the dishes for Sunday
like Saturday is fun day and it's
important I think to put up the the
blocks on your calendar to more not just
like what you are going to do but what
you're not going to do
I'm not going to
get interrupted by my team today I am
not going to work on my YouTube channel
today I am not going to and I think that
that really helps you stay a lot more
focused
and then my last is quick thought and
then we can open up if you want me to go
in deeper and Michael know you're here
so if you got questions on that this is
kind of top level but it also lets you
miss the work I like to miss the work
like you guys we see each other once a
week now it's like I miss you guys in
between
you know it's like we get this and then
tomorrow I'm not missing you but then
come like Tuesday Wednesday like when we
get the reader's group and then Thursday
comes you're like Hey we're back
and so if you only do something once a
week you're always missing it when it
comes up
so I haven't made YouTube videos since
Tuesday I'm not missing it yet but come
like Friday Saturday it's like oh I want
to make I want to make some YouTube
videos so whatever day I'm about to jump
into I'm always missing the work as
opposed to kind of getting bored
overwhelmed or whatever from it
um so that's really helped me and again
you may not be able to control your
whole day
but whatever you can control just being
intentional with it and asking yourself
hey over the next week I've got seven
days and inside inside of that I've got
14 hours that I can play with I'm gonna
use those 14 hours
that are my time to be able to move
closer to achieving the goals I've got
for myself
that's my quick my quick take Michael to
help or you guys got extra questions you
want to dive deeper on it I got another
question
can I ask yeah yeah Michael then we'll
go to we'll go to Nile that's how his
hand up too what do you got
all right so at the end of the day do
you have a time that you stop with your
work and then that's your family time
time to spend with your kid uh or with
the wife or are you like until you go to
bed uh like you're on making videos
until 8 p.m and then you do your bedtime
routine and go to bed
so if I look at a normal breakdown
um with kind of family time so we'll
I'll go for a walk with my wife in the
morning so I'll take the dogs out then
we'll go for a walk and we spend the
first 45 minutes to an hour of the day
kind of just setting up for the day
we're both not morning people so at the
beginning we're not really talking
it's kind of like holding hands and
walking outside
uh and then as like the Sun hits you and
the fresh air we start
having a conversation hey how's it
what's up for today how'd you sleep last
night and just kind of I like walking in
the day with some fresh air and not just
being inside all the time
um especially now with everything going
on it's like we don't get enough
outside stuff that we get to do
um then usually we'll take a break at 2
30.
uh we both have that in our calendar it
was a break for half an hour 2 30 to
connect it could be
um
depending on how we're feeling it could
be another like quick outside just take
the dog to the park super quick come
back up but that kind of built into our
schedule
um after that I'll go back to work uh
usually until at least five five to six
is like my buffer zone for anything
urgent
so
you know today is my interview day I
actually have a gap from five to six but
I put that in because we booked so far
in advance for guests for my me to be on
shows that if something really urgent
comes up I hate having to post postpone
somebody or cancel on somebody like
worst case we can but if some big
opportunity comes up we have that as our
buffer zone just kind of like hotels off
in the the penthouse suite is open just
in case some big person comes in there's
a room for them they have to kick
somebody out
um 6 to 7 30 ish I'm doing my live
stream usually four days a week with Zan
here and and Drew and then from 7 30 to
what nine
uh it's usually playing with the kids
uh right now we're doing a lot of
Minecraft together uh because three
different cities you know nieces and
nephews all that stuff we just join on
the Minecraft server together I'm not
very good at Minecraft
um but whatever it's a fun thing to do
and I think there's a lot of actual life
lessons that happen like if you go and
you build your character in Minecraft
and then you step into lava and you lose
all your stuff do you rage quit and
freak out or can you talk that through
right and like I think you can parent
and teach and life lessons through
everything and the more you're doing
things that they like as opposed to like
forcing to do what you want
um there's actually better teaching
there
nine to ten Nina and I usually watch a
show right now we're watching Homeland
uh we're on the last season of Homeland
working our way through usually we're
watching like some of the superhero
movies or shows uh Legends of tomorrow
and what else we watch Green Arrow
uh anyway there was this big gap of no
shows coming out it's like oh we got
nothing to watch so we fell into home
line and that's pretty good
um but that's one hour
then I wash the dishes take the dogs out
um answer the questions I do like 10
questions 11. and then we get ready for
bed
um
so that's a typical like Monday to
Friday kind of day Friday night would
probably just stay up a little bit later
and do stuff together but that's a
typical weekday so uh there's a morning
time there's an afternoon time when
there's an evening time
um spread out between like just the two
of us or time with family too so far
works but it's constant like Minor
Adjustments as we go Nile what'd you got
hey can you hear me today yeah we got
you yeah excellent yes hey your wall is
basically the same as mine dude it's
just it's it's orange I don't I I mine's
orange yours is coming through with
yours kind of looks red just a little
lighter but I like it dude this is great
thanks and listen I have been I haven't
had a chance to speak this is fantastic
at what you're doing here and um I think
this is great and everything that people
share is fantastic you mind if I take it
off topic just for a little bit from the
scheduling or do you want to focus you
know whatever whatever you guys want one
quick question I had was what would you
suggest or what's your thought on
building a brand on you as a person
compared to building a brand around an
entity or a company name or a theme
person's always easier okay your story
is your greatest advantage
why is somebody going to buy from you
versus some giant Corporation because
they feel like you actually care about
them
but where you lose is you don't have the
history you don't have the reputation
you don't have the name brand yet you
think about whoever the biggest
competitors are in your industry like
why it's the old expression nobody got
fired for buying IBM
um like the big brands that they're
trusted so they may not treat you super
well but at least you know what you're
getting and they have a history and
they're likely not going to screw you
over
um so if you're if you're a logo
you're basically taking the worst of
Both Worlds where if you make it your
personal brand they may not they may not
know you yet but it's like man this guy
cares
that's why sharing your story right I
mean
why emphasize so much in here is sharing
your story matters is what makes people
connect to you that okay maybe you don't
have the history of the reputation yet
but man I feel like this guy actually
cares about me and I wanna I wanna
I want to do business with him and how
about it sorry how about if the theme
itself uh Builds on and stems from my
story and how I could further serve
that's that's where I'm thinking of
going I've just reinhanded myself but I
rebranded myself but it wasn't it's not
me necessarily it's me I'm all that's on
on my branding but it's backed by a
mantra
that has to tie to your your purpose of
course yeah that's why you tell your
story because that's who you're trying
to help in reading your story I need to
feel like oh my God this guy gets me
right this guy is exactly who I am and I
need I need his help like you're you're
a hundred steps ahead but you're the
same person and so I can learn from you
because
you get me that's your biggest Advantage
your story is your biggest Advantage as
an entrepreneur right right I just
didn't know if it would be possession
from hey Nile it's me or the concept of
my brand not the concept but the
positioning of my brain so it it opens
up something that becomes familiar
um very similar to your your one word
that's that's where yeah like you are
your brand right right so it's not this
isn't this is what happened with your
one word and then build the service
believe isn't just a strategy for me
I am believe it's my who same thing for
all you guys like when you figure out
your who it's who you are and you show
up
everywhere as that so I I right now I'm
believing in you guys and I'm believing
all the people that I'm doing shows with
afterwards but when I when I come home
and still believe it's still spreading
belief to my wife and my family it's
it's it takes on a different life right
I'm not telling Nina go make your
YouTube content and spread your message
but it's still you know believing in her
so it's not just a hat that you wear
it's actually who you are so Nile equals
blank not just oh this is my business
stands for this but I stand for
something different
right perfect thank you
varindra yeah yeah and that's right
thank you thank you thank you for having
these sessions you are wonderful to have
you thanks a lot first of all and uh hi
everyone my question is on this point
you just mentioned about the one word so
I got your one word book now so reading
through it but if you get kind of help
in terms of how we find it and will be
uh you know get that through quickly so
we can start more
did you go through the five questions
of like your favorite teacher I I have
just started reading you yesterday only
so I have got to that point the chapter
two where the five questions are there
so I'll be going to answer them okay so
that that honestly that's the best thing
like go through the questions the both
books were not designed as just uh
read the book and put it away it's like
it's it's a you have to think you have
to do the exercises you know it's a it's
almost a workbook inside a book
um if you want to get the value out of
it I think the best thing is go through
the questions and if you get stuck
come back next week and and we'll
Workshop it
okay yeah fine fine thank you
I saw a lady had her hand up lady Alexey
I'm trying to figure out how to work my
schedule uh as in uh recording videos
and all the other stuff ever since I've
been dealing with the death of my mom
and my kids and I'm swamped by
whether it's an appointment with the
attorney cleaning up the house
um you name it real estate agents of
course my brother my sister but you know
I have limited amount of energy I have
to juggle through it all so you were
talking about your schedule during the
day and I'm like okay how would I be
able to maintain some sort of schedule
uh along with the regular clients I've
got and and trying to get my story
online that's actually why I didn't
record because I was so tired at night
so you know there are moments where you
need to give yourself more grace right
and and you know sorry to hear about
your mom and your cat and
um you know we lost our family dog uh
not too long ago and
uh some people you know see that as
mushy or whatever but that's a big deal
like it's part of your family
um we also lost uh my sister-in-law last
year at the end of the year
um like 40 years old I did some super
rare cancer three kids
um one teen and two pre-teens and that
uh
that took us all out
you know I was not being nearly as
productive as I could have been
um
uh I wasn't doing as many shows as I
usually had my Wednesday or Friday might
have been completely gone instead of
doing creative work I'm spending the
time with my nieces or nephews just
not even doing much is being with them
because their mom just died and what do
you do is an eight-year-old right just
to have some kind of
love their um they're still you know
they were trying to figure out school or
no school and just dealing with it
um so this Grace you know there are some
moments in life where you have to give
yourself a little bit more grace and
understand that you're not going to be
at your regular capacity when I broke my
neck you know
that was brutal
but I still made videos every day you
know I think like having something that
you can hang your hat on to
to even if you're even if you're tired
even if you're not 100 just to look back
and say like I'm still not giving up on
my ambitions
so whatever that looks like for you like
if making videos is really important to
you I would still make videos and post
like you can make a five minute video I
made a video from my hospital bed with
my broken neck and a concussion
and
Doug Wilder is not here in the house
right now but he took a screenshot of it
and it looks like I'm dead
I mean it's probably just a bad
screenshot too but I've got my neck
brace on like this giant scab across my
forehead and it was definitely not
anywhere close to being my best content
but I'm you know looking back super
proud that I still did it
to do the difficult thing when it's hard
it was my best content it was a five
minute video instead of I committed to
going live every day
right while I was on my tour and
everybody
yeah
so it's it's okay to to let go of the
structure you know with opinion and all
that stuff and just post like one minute
videos and
you know without the beginning and the
ends you know the bumper and food are
let go of all that
at the end of the day all that matters
is how proud are you of yourself
are you proud that you did the best that
you could give him what you had
so if you're gonna say hey I can either
not make a video because it's not
perfect or I can make a one minute video
with everything else going on but it
won't have to structure I'd rather you
make the one minute video
okay
I I did record them I just didn't post
them uh yeah all of them and I did write
notes so I would like to go in it you
know after all
post and then recognize now if it's a
year later and you're still
here that's a problem right so like
there's a grace period and grief is real
right but if it's three years later and
you're still in grief and you still
can't do anything then that's that's a
bigger problem that we need to to work
through but for the most part I think of
all the negative emotions
you know if you think positive emotions
like courage and ambition and drive and
service and all that and negative
emotions of of fear and anger and
jealousy and all of that
every negative emotion I want to try to
eliminate from my life except for grief
grief is a special one like I don't want
to have jealousy in my life I don't want
to have anger or or
um any of the like strong negative
emotions but grief not that I want grief
in my life but it's it it just has to be
worked through
like if I'm jealous about somebody I
don't want to work I want to fix it and
get rid of it I don't want to be jealous
of other people but grief you can't just
get rid of it like if you dive into your
work
it's still there
you know you can't just forget about it
and so you have to work through it and
time will heal and you won't be as
productive as you could be normally
would be and that's fine there's a
little bit of Grace I think all of us
and if you haven't had any grief yet
it's it's gonna happen at some point I
mean it's just the Human Experience oh I
I did I did have it and of course I
still go to to start to be like two
times a week for my ankles so you know
it's juggling with limited amount of
energy but I I also noticed that I
really want to continue on with the
business the drive is there
so release make your one minute videos
and release it
okay thank you
join us
your questions you can go get the book
right there next to me right there I'll
see you there I'll see you to get the
book it's a good one much love